讓我兩把過來學習這個班
好
就是
跟我聊
好
跟你聊好了
來
接受我
好
接受一下
我是華晶隊的朱飛飛
那今天就是受了一個
緣分的邀請
我正在開了一個JF客機
所以我教到我們和Volk8D
那是一些使用
因為現在AI是這樣的一個大時代
男生都要學AI
所以其實我們一直都有在學習
但是因為可能離AI的距離
就是有點遠
所以就學的技術都比較慢
所以但是今天這兩天
我們來這裡聽宏爺
還有剛才的一位老師
一邊講的很細
然後對對
我們的工作很大
特別就是
昨天我們也講到一些具體的操作
一邊講
然後一邊讓我們做一些實操
覺得說話很大
對
好
OK
那我就繼續提問
現在有大量的網上的一些AI課程
那你其實學習的時候也可以上AI課的提問
那你覺得為甚麼我們要去參加一些
現下的課程
然後的課程呢
就是實際上
剛才我們今天聽了課以後
可能老師反復的告訴我們說
有甚麼不會的實在你就問AI就好了
AI都會交給你
但是有時候其實可能也是一個亂性
我們從小說的教育一直就是
老師教我們要這樣這樣這樣
思維還沒有那麼快的轉變過來說
我有甚麼不會
實際上我就問了
AI是最好的老師
所以還有一個慣性
但是我覺得這個
這個習慣
這個跟這個AI時代的發展
它應該慢慢慢慢真的會轉變
就是說實際上人人都可以
把AI就是自己的老師
所以還需要一個過程
所以我們現在需要到線下來試試
好
OK
那基本上OK
我們的這一次採訪
好
然後就可以先把BiPhone摘下來
我在裡面
在這裡